hello everyone and welcome to Game three
of the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between a Vishwanath on Island and
Magnus Carlsen now as if you've seen my
previous two videos then you know Game
one was a relatively short game cross
and had the white pieces
Game two was there was a bit more fight
in Game two but also the game ended in a
well not not the quickest of draws but a
relatively quick draw and if you
consider a Game one was definitely at
least a moral victory for cross and as
he I meant for Anand as he really you
know really prepared well for the game
and he said our cousin has nothing with
the white pieces and the second game did
kind of go to Carson but then we
returned to game number three and here
as Carson didn't really have any
problems in Game one but he didn't
really achieve anything in Game one so
maybe he will definitely change
something to his approach the question
is what
so before we check out the game and this
is a very nice game an incredibly
fighting game let's check out some of
the photos from round 3 so here we have
another photo from the opening
photographers still behind the glass
wall nothing out of the ordinary here
although we did see in my video from
Game two that cross and does have that
those soda bottles which is name on it
although you will never actually see the
soda bottles and during the games or
maybe we will have to see the entire
series to figure this out so here we
have another photo and here a nice
close-up of Magnus Carlsen so let's
check out the game so here we have knife
to f3 Carson opens b5 g 3 g6 and here in
game number one across him went for
Bishop to g2 but here he mixes things up
with the early c4 so still deciding what
he will do with the D pawn and he run
and immediately captures it D captures
on c4 Carson goes Queen to a4 Queen and
Knights to a3 is also possible going for
the pawn this way but talent has a
couple of nice with victories with the
black pieces in this line so instead
cosmos for Queen 2a4 definitely a
prepared variation and he thinks that
aren't will maybe and not do so well in
this line Knight to the c6 Bush of the
g2 now Bishop to g7 and now Knight to c3
c5 we have Queen captures on c4 and
Knight G to e7
we have castles castles and d3 now h6
Bishop to d2 and Knight the d4 this is a
canoe this was considered a novelty at
the time although it seems Anand found
this novelty over the board because it's
very hard and to consider that he was
prepared for this variation usually
Bishop to e6 is played here simply
developing a piece while attacking the
Queen but here after knife to d4 it's a
very interesting move now delaying the
development of this Bishop but the
division can now be developed to e6 but
also to g4 so giving Carlsen a lot to
consider here across an immediately
grabs the night we have Knight captures
it captures and mount Knight to e4 c6
and now comes Bishop to b4 this was
considered to be an inaccuracy by
Carlsen but the line that was suggested
after the game as an improvement not not
an easy one to find over the board Queen
to c1 simply going after the h6 pawn and
now after f5 attacking the knight Knight
moves King to h7 defending now simply
bring the Queen back to c4 and you've
improved the position of your night
you've you've wealth ruined blacks King
side quite a bit and you returned the
Queen to see for a nice active square
and the rooks are ready to be developed
so it seems very simple but when you're
playing the game you know it's very very
hard to find things like this so after
c6 Bishop to b4 pinning Islands 937 we
have Bishop to e6 attacking the Queen
now Queen to c1 although Queen to see
one now is without a tempo dh6 pawn is
is under new attack Bishop to d5 and now
a four we have b6 Bishop to e7 capturing
Queen captures and now comes a five this
was a very exciting moment in the game
Anand is better here he has the bishop
prepare his
decision is excellent and f5s coming
Carson will really have to figure out
what to do here he will be completely
passive if this is allowed and he finds
a very nice active idea that is a five
and by playing a five he has to consider
a whole lot of things of course be
captures on a five is out of the
question
there's really no reason to do this
pushing b5 again doesn't really make any
sense
Queen to c5 really activates the Queen
will either force an exchange of Queens
or or create a very nice square for the
knight on c5 another thing to consider
is f5 so does a5 prevent this f5 move in
fact it does because after knife to d2
you can't really capture on any - if
Queen captures then rook to e1 and then
you have to bring your queen out of the
game for example Queen to h5 now comes a
captures a captures Bishop captures will
check captures rook captures rook
captures and after Queen to c6 the black
queen is out of the game but the white
queen is extremely active she'll start
grabbing those pawns a much better
position for white and the reason you
have to bring your queen out of the game
after this f5 move and like we said
knife to d2 if you capture and then rook
e1 u cannot capture the pawn on d3 this
is the whole point you have to move the
Queen if you capture it then Bishop to
f1 and your queen is trapped on d3 there
is nowhere to go
another idea after this f5 and nice to
be - you could exchange your bishops
first the bishop captures King captures
and only then capture on e2 but still it
doesn't help you a capture some b6 and
now the point is you cannot recapture on
b6 if you recapture then rook captures
rook captures and now rook to e1 queen
captor son d3 and now again Queen
captures on c6 the whole point of this
entire a fire move is that the Queen
will always capture and c6 with an
attack on the rook so after Queen walks
this and then comes Queen captures and
g6 and blacks position is shattered
white white it will be better here so
after this if I move on and figures this
out and he plays rook a to b8
not going for this f5 move
now after all the seven run Carson plays
rook e1 and now the eto point is
protected so f5 is is no big deal
rook F to c8 and is now preparing to
push those pawns we have a captures pawn
captures and Queen to f4 now we have
rogue back to the 8th on and doesn't
allow Carson to take any advantage of
the d6 square cross in place
h4 King to h7 and now nights to d2 a
very dangerous move I fall if h4 was
already played in h v g5 Queen to a5
check would have been a simple way to go
about this but Carson really really goes
and complicates things
Knight the d2 and now he really the
Queen doesn't have a good retreat paths
so on and immediately takes advantage of
this Bishop to e5 attacking the Queen
Queen to g4 and now h5 and the Queen is
really running out of squares to hide
Queen to h3 and now Bishop to h6 and now
crossing place Queen to h1 and if you
look at this cross unenforced crossing
screen all the way to h1 and it will be
extremely hard to get the screen back
into the game and pushes c5 now he's
ready to push b4 c4 b3 b2 and Causton
definitely has to do something about
this Carson plays Knight to e4 and when
Carson played Knight to e4 a lot of
Grand Master said that this is in fact
the losing move of this game or that the
position that you know arises after 94
is a losing position for white they
suggested b3 simply stopping blacks
expansion on the Queen side but
interestingly nice the e4 is is
definitely alright and it is a move
recommended by the engine so King to g7
was played now comes Knight to g5
attacking the bishop there we have b5
nikons III D captures on e3 rook
captures on e3 and Bishop to d4 and this
was also one of the more critical
moments in the game here Anand doesn't
capture the b2 pawn when in fact
capturing the b2 pawn is definitely the
way to go after you capture
yes rook 831 is coming
there will be a very nice attack on this
e6 pawn but this is the variation you
have to find rook to d6 defending and
now Bishop to d5 of course this is the
idea piling up on the bishop on e6 now
comes Bishop to b4 attacking the rook
Knight captures pawn captures rook
captures rook captures rook captures and
this is now the move you had to find in
order to be able to capture the pawn on
b2 Queen to f8 now you get out of the
attack but also threaten Queen captures
on F - checkmate
and now after Weiss it defends this
either with rook to e - or maybe Queen
to g2 doesn't really matter
rookie - now before is coming and it's
still gonna be a much better position
for black and it's hard to say if black
can push this to win but you know this
pawn is a passed pawn and you know it's
a pretty fast passport so it wouldn't be
all that simple for white to stop this
definitely the way to go but to be able
to capture Bishop capture some b2 you
have to find that Queen to f8 move if
you don't then it will be very hard to
capture the pawn so instead Island plays
Bishop to d4 he attacks the rook rook to
e2 now the B to pawn is defended and now
C for Anand continues pushing on the
Queen side Knight captures on e6f
captures on e6 and now Bishop to e4
rook to a6 was also an idea but across
and prefers a bishop to e4
we have seek after sandy 3 and now rook
the D - upon sacrifice but it will give
cost and a lot of activity and here
again cousin one goes for Queen to b4
again you should take advantage of DF
file with a look to f8 then you pretty
much force matters into blacks advantage
after Bishop captures on d3 now comes
Queen to d6
threatening Queen captures on g3 as the
F pawn is pinned so after you prevent
this Queen to g2 then comes rook
captures on f2
rook captures and now the other look
comes to f8 you are attacking the pink
piece on f2
after rogue blocks then comes rook
captures captures captures captures and
captures and you will get a queen in
pawned endgame where black
is up upon and you know this should be
winning for black if black who could win
this you know it would have to be tested
but definitely the position you would
want to go to but Anand doesn't go for
rook to a fate he goes Queen to be for
attacking the rook on D to Luke 8 to d1
defending and now again rook to f8 is
possible but now it's it's it it's not
so strong as a move before so here
aren't pretty much forces forces matters
he plays a Bishop capture some beat do
we have Queen to f3 Bishop to f6 getting
out of the way and now rook captures and
III rook captures rook captures and here
rook to d8 we have rook captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop to d3 putting
pressure on that b5 point Bishop
captures and g6 doesn't really do all
that much for white after Bishop capture
skin captures yes you do have Queen to
d3 check and winning the bishop so you
did win a pawn here but after King year
7 Queen captures Queen e1 check King
moves and now before it's only black if
white makes a mistake it's only black
that can take advantage of this position
white can't really take advantage of
this position
so after this Bishop to d8 Causton goes
at Bishop to d3 we have Queen to d4 here
on and offers calls and his extra pawn
so basically offering the draw bishop
capture somebody if I was played and now
Queen to f6
Anand offers a trade of Queens and
offers a draw but it's in this position
that Carlsen actually declines the draw
he plays Queen to be 7 this is move 41
this comes with a check tank control has
been reached and he forces on earth to
play on well it's a completely wrong
position maybe with the Queens on the
board okay whitey does have a slightly
better pawn structure but it's it's
impossible to believe that this could
turn out any other way than a draw but
either he wants to play on maybe maybe
just tire on and for the next round or
maybe it's some sort of psychological
warfare or maybe just to annoy him calls
and forces Anand to play this game on
so Bishop to e7 blocking King to g2 we
have g5h captures Queen captures
Bishop to c4 and now h4 here you don't
really achieve anything by playing
Bishop
capture still captures captures Queen d2
this comes with the check and black will
be be able to force a perpetual check
and draw the game this way
so after h4 Queen to c7 is played by
Carlsen we have H captures Queen
captures on g3 and now e5 King to f3 now
finally on captures the Queen Queen
captures pawn captures Bishop to c5 and
after king e4 Bishop to d4 this is now a
completely drawn endgame Bishop to f2
ping g5 capturing and Bishop captures
and g3 with check but in this position
the players finally agreed to a draw so
definitely a very interesting and a very
fighting game were only on and had some
chances to actually win this game so
although it's a third game in a row that
in a row that was drawn in this match
definitely another moral victory for
Viswanathan Anand as was the one in Game
one
so definitely cousin will will have to
change his approach in game half 5 when
he once again gets the white pieces so
that's the game Game three of the 2013
World Chess Championship match between
Anand and Carson I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Danny McCulloch
DK Griffiths Kyle Pascoe thing wrong and
Doug was right for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here they will both be from this
match Game one and Game two
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with Game four of this
wonderful historic match so thank you
all and I'll see you soon